so I'm going to talk about market
service websites so in the beginning of
last year we I started to work quite
early in the face with a concept for a
new mobile first website for IKEA and
during the summer last year we released
the first like MVP you might say a
static blog a key M to the static site
blog and then this summer we have
released IKEA M to Norway which is a
pilot of a mobile first full full IKEA
site so this site consists of five
different services or applications and
this is going to be my example in this
talk today how how we use these concepts
to basically do a mash-up between these
five different five different services
and applications so that end user only
feels that there's there's one one site
and not five different just to be clear
we also have made some partial loss in
other markets so we have two or three
services running there as well so it's
not only Norway and right now we're
working on some desktop better desktop
web support for for these kinds of
devices browsers so first of all if we
go back why did why did the project even
why was it created in the first place so
one thing was that the old web site had
some performance problems so that was
the first thing that we burned to
address that really really great web
performance for especially for mobile
devices and but after that we realized
that we wanted to find an approach that
made could make a scale in terms of
horizontal scaling and development wise
so we can have more many teams working
on different parts of the of the web and
to be able to deploy autonomously
scalable development and then lastly we
also we also realized that we didn't
want to make another rewrite like five
or seven years ten years from now we
wanted to have an evolvable system so
that we can take parts piece by piece
and lift them to something new and
better and so we don't have to make this
whole transaction of making from one web
to another kind of web and this is going
to be the structure of my talk today so
these three things three different parts
may also be seen as design constraints
and this Venn Benesch diagram here these
are design constraints and we want to
find solution in the middle here and
just to be clear this this might not be
your design constraints in your
organization source or our companies but
I think that if you have an external
website performance is is quite
important and if you want to build web
websites with more than one team you
need you need would be curious about
what I have to say as well but if you
only have one web leaf ultimate team
your life is going to be so much easier
so it's a code it's of course a trade
off and this does just only apply if you
have more than one team and also maybe
you don't want to have an evolvable
solution maybe if the it's going to be
evaluated like five years from now if if
the business case is still valid then
you can make it rewrite so just want to
be here about that so let's again very
briefly about performance and this is
not a web performance talk but I want to
have this as a base the performance is
quite easy when you start building
websites because basically hello world
is the most performant webpage and then
it basically decorates from that from
there so you want to have this is a base
and make sure that we don't degrade
performance as we go and develop the
architecture
so there's a nice very nice report from
Miss West uh which is part of Akamai now
with where these graphs are shown and
they show conversion rate how the how
the conversion rate is affected by
end-user performance and page load time
so here we see that if you disregard the
first two seconds which is basically
four fours and 500 HTTP status codes you
see that the conversion rates start to
drop off to two seconds so you have you
have up to two seconds of page load time
before something bad happens and this is
both on desktop mobile and tablets and
all kinds of devices but it could be
different behaviors so for for IKEA the
whole IKEA calm web has over two billion
visits last year so the conversion rate
is quite important for for a key as a
whole so we really want to have good
performance done and be below this -
second - second limit so there's a nice
oh sorry so our strategy just very
simplified has been to as much as
possible when applicable have as a
simple server-side render HTML pages as
possible and then for other use cases to
do something else but that's our like
base we want to make something as simple
as possible and of course that's
sometimes hard but yeah with with some
solutions to other problems we also use
HTTP - which makes things in idioms
impure simpler we don't need to bundle a
lot of stuff that you have to do with
they should be one so this approach has
given us great page load performance and
then you might wonder how but how great
is it really
there's a story here that the Norwegian
web manager Nina went to an external
conference and there the the manager for
Google Norway had representation about
how to survive digitization era and web
performance and they have made some
surveys and performance tests on the
major sites in the Norway and according
to him the story was quite sad because
there was no site in Norway that had a
patient load time below 1 second except
one and that was the IKEA m2 norway site
that we had released just earlier a few
months before so that's a great success
story and great approval that we have we
have good performance in our in our
solution but moving on to the topic of
this talk market service web sites and
the scalable development again we want
to make sure that we don't degrade
performance when we add things and
complexity so if we move up an
abstraction ladder we there is a concept
of to pizza team to pizza team rule from
Amazon that I think Jeff basis has
coined the CEO that team should not be
larger than they could be fed by two
American pizzas which is for me at least
around 10 people so so fairly large
family pizzas depends on I Marcia eat of
course it's nice constraint that maybe
you could get away with 12 people of 13
people but you're hungry so you need to
find a way out of that situation so
how many of you know Conway's law out
quite a few so simplified if we want to
have these teams these team sizes of
like ten people or so following Conway's
law we need to have services that are
small enough for one of these teams to
handle so we want to have use this
isomorphism of Conway's law and I'd like
one service per team and maybe one team
can have more services but this should
be at least bigger this granular and not
more not larger services than this so in
our case we have these five different
services for ikm to Norway it's a
simplified picture but it's good enough
for example so we have these teams they
make software and they want to deploy
autonomously and be independent of each
other but the usual way would be to
integrate these teams in a common front
and the front end application which is a
problem because these teams can't get
out get their software out the door
because they're they're being stuffed by
the by the fronton team and the backlog
just keeps growing and growing it's very
tempting to add just more people to the
project and three product and then you
have this bad a feedback loop of adding
more code more people more bugs nothing
can be done a diminishing return and a
bad bad final state so one what we want
to have is to have these have the front
and being part of these services as well
so that each service on their own front
and from from as much as possible so
that they are self organized they can
develop release and test themselves
operationally responsible and they own
the whole lifecycle of the services they
create
and for example for for our product
products team here they are integrating
further down below the stack of course
there are some product database which
are have a number of years have lived
quite a few years but as much as
possible aiming for this picture so it
doesn't stop there because we want we
want to find a way for these to
collaborate with content because now
they are independent websites basically
and we want we want to be able to share
the content between the services so that
for example the menu is shown on every
page and we have these fragments here
for products for example on the search
page but also on the like more
inspirational content below the picture
here so we have titles and prices and
some campaigns and these these this
information we want to be updated as as
fast as possible so we really really
want to reuse the contents in some form
of components so for us we have we are
relying heavily on a concept called
transfusion which was coined by Ted
Nelson in the book literal missions in
1980 and the concept is very simple and
here you're using it every day today
when you're browsing the web so you have
this large document like a web page and
it's having a reference to my smaller
document the fragment may be JavaScript
files it says file an image and the
browser in terms of client side
transfusion is making it seem like this
is one document and is kind of including
the fragment into the into the consuming
document itself
so the the only difference with between
what what you would usually use in
browsers and what we are using in the
IKEA m2 project is that we transclude
HTML from the fragments to the web page
and there's two different ways that you
can transclude you can transcode on the
client side like like you normally do
and also on the server side which i'm
going to talk a bit about in a few
slides but just to be clear this concept
here allows us to cross the service and
team boundary so that pages from one
service and team can access fragments
from another server some team and so
this allows us to collaborate between
services and building this kind of
mash-up between different web pages so
si-h that includes is a service side
transfusion technique technology it was
a standard proposal in 2001 so it's a
fairly stable fairly stable spec even if
it's not a formal standard w3c standard
it's implemented in various idioms like
Akamai and fastly and has nginx and
Apache plug-in support and also there's
quite a few libraries that you allows
you to add at a site to your web service
for example no DSi as NPM package and it
works like this that when the end end
user makes a request its hitch hits some
form of edge web server if it's on a CDN
if it's on your your web servers or
something in between doesn't really
matter but like the outmost web server
before their requests hits the end user
so then Lisa makes requests to ash web
server and it's fetching from the origin
and the origin document contains a nice
I include tag on the way back the edge
web server TSI implementation parses
document and sees these assign to tags
and makes HTTP requests to the source
attribute in the include tag and when
those HTTP requests are resolved we
replace the ESI include tag with the
contents of the fragment and return the
page to the end user and the end user
and user has no idea that the resulting
document was actually being have several
parts and there was some some kind of
collaboration between the scenes here so
it's totally opaque it might be good to
remember though that this is a bit of a
costly operation because you need to
parse every document that goes through
this pipe so you might want to cache
this for for some time we cache it in 15
minutes which is good for our use cases
and let's just shake yeah and before I
move on I want to say this that I think
that edge site includes
is the most underrated web technology
today and you should really have a look
at it and this this phrase is so
important that are going to say it once
again ESI is one of the most underrated
web technologies out there today and you
should really have a look at it okay so
now hopefully you remember something
from my talk so if we moved it to the
client side you can do basically the
same thing with Ajax so I made an web
component custom element to porch of
Marc Nottingham's ashing to the dirtiest
and it's worked a similar way as
sigh so the browser now sees an Asian
clue tag and it's making a just requests
to the URL in the source attribute and
it's replacing the the contents of the
ejector Ajax responses replacing the
innerhtml with the contents of responses
but this is just an example it's fairly
easy to just make some a just requests
and replace some inner HTML with
responses and there exists other similar
libraries to this and I want to be clear
that the IKEA empty part is not using
this in production but I think it's nice
because it makes you shift between ESI
and a she clued very very very easy
alright so when should you use ESI and
when she did use Ajax I'm a consultant
so it depends of course but what does it
depend on well I think that since it's
nice that we do a lot of stuff behind
the scenes and also to as much as
possible support non JavaScript browsers
and get get great performance it should
use ESI as a base technology for doing
translation but then you could use Ajax
you you should use a jamais Constitution
for personalized content city wants to
want to cache the results also to use
its Ajax transition when you have for
example have client-side rendered page
just like single page applications and
maybe just JavaScript components because
you're no longer on the server side when
you're rendering under in the client
side of course and maybe do some lazy
loading for content below the fold so
you don't put so much pressure on the
web server and also make the patient
load time seem better so yeah so this
has allowed us to share content between
between the different services the menu
the different product fragments and
another screenshot here on the right the
front page but we're not done here
what about styling because now we can
transclude HTML between different
services but just HTML enough won't cut
it
because it will not look great if you
say the least
so here you have basically three
different options you could just look at
HTML as a consumer and they just
reimplemented a CSS according to some
style guide or you could agree on some
form of implementation of a common CSS
framework like bootstrap but for for our
solution and you could also find a way
to export CSS and optionally JavaScript
from the fragment producers producers so
that it's possible to import by the
fragment consumers and the two first
options I think creates a high amount of
coupling the more coupling the more
teams the more coupling you have and the
third option is what we want to have
here because that gives us a high
cohesion because the HTML and CSS has
been crafted by the same team so a first
approach here would just be for a
consuming team to just have a static
reference to a CSS and maybe a
javascript file but since we want to
have an very very long cache time for
CSS and JavaScript files because it's a
good practice and we get good
performance as well we use this cache
busting - post hashes in the name and
this becomes a problem because if we
want to update this as a CSS file the
name name change so we make basically to
mail every email every consumer of that
file saying well yeah here's the new
version
maybe point the reference to that
instead so we can deploy we have this
deployment of the CSS file everywhere so
we need some form of and that's not too
really good so we need some formal
inversion here and we're in m2 we are
using ESI as this inversion layer so
instead of the webpage referring to CSS
file directly it's doing si transclusion
to a file that we call a fragment
resource a research fragment that is
referring to a specific cache bastard
CSS file or JavaScript so that the
fragment consumers never know about a
specific version of a file so it might
also be good to know that we're now not
talking about fragment instances but
rather about fragment types because you
don't want to include one CSS file for
every fragment instance that you consume
only the fragment type so we have some
form of type type notion here I don't
want go into anything more in detail but
that's it so these two concepts of
translation and research fragments has
allowed us to to have these five
different teams and services and deploy
the deploy these autonomously and have
high high degree of Independence between
the teams so we are doing one or two
releases per week per team which is not
continuous delivery but it's quite good
and did the different team can adapt and
release more aggressively if they want
or it depends on their on their domain
on their problem and as a system as a
whole we have around five to eight
prussians releases per per week which if
you would translate this to the old way
of them of the monolith would be a
really really huge number maybe for a
similar thing there's a lot of
coordination costs of all with not not
having this division of different
services
are you done are you done we're done
yeah we're not done you know you know
the drill so this allows us to have
really a lot of releases and to have a
fast pace and it seems to be independent
of each other so moving on to well of
ability because even if we even if it
were nice state right now the world
changes we don't know about the future
we know that client-side libraries tend
to evolve and change every zones of
years and we want to make sure as much
as possible
to some some kind of extent that we're
able to evolve the solution over time so
we don't make need to make this big
rewrite in the future and now I'm going
to go a little on the side and talk
about briefly about alternative art
architectures for components so there's
a tag on Twitter called micro phantoms
which I believe that this micro service
websites architecture is part of this
style of developing us at least
composable us on the web so and if you
look at the links on that twitter
hashtag you see two different approaches
basically so either you say we
standardize on one-on-one library maybe
react or something else and let all our
components be our all shareable
components we've written in react or we
can have this diversity of different
frameworks and libraries on the client
side so I'm going to go through both of
these but start with the second one
so with this style I think we have a
really bad performance problem if we
follow this ID and if we if we value
performance because if people if web
developers have a problem today with
getting good performance out of one
framework a library
client-side library and also using kind
of an isomorphic approach maybe if
they're advanced it's going to be quite
hard to load this different client-side
libraries to download them parse them
evaluate them and not having a degraded
performance compared to having one
library or maybe having enough no
library at all so I think that a
client-side diversity in terms of
frameworks and libraries are not very
very good in within the same page the
web web is a fantastic diverse place but
just within a single page we don't value
diversity we shouldn't value diversity
because it becomes becomes a performance
problem so but just to conclude here the
glue here between this components is is
the web components custom elements which
i think is a really nice technology but
just having having multiple libraries on
the same page it's not a good thing for
performance so if you then take the
opposite opposite approach say that we
standardize on one library
react just being an example and saying
that every team should use react we use
we are writing our all our components in
react and sharing them between the teams
I think this is a scalable overtime
problem and maybe it's more obvious if
you look at this this way and we have
this five different different services
and sometime in the future we might say
that we want to move to another library
and inevitably that will probably be the
case some number of years from now
inhabit hypothetical case so how should
we do this move from react to maybe view
without hitting this problem of having
this combination of libraries and
frameworks which we know is a
performance problem I think it probably
can be done by some basic abstracting
away both of these libraries which is a
kind of costly development operations to
do and basically doing a rewrite but
just in another way and rewrites is it's
something that I have a quite big
problem with because the business
doesn't get anything out of it
it basically it just solves a technology
problem so if we can avoid this we
really want to we really should I think
and that this doesn't mean that that
reactor view or any library is bad yes
that having this using them as a glue
for integrating between different
services in a micro Service website or
front-end is a bad idea I think so what
did we do well we're using transclusion
but we need to submit to find a way what
to to know what common dependencies can
a fragment can fragment producers assume
that's our way of framing the problem of
how to how to write components because
we know we need CSS for components but
some components might also need
JavaScript and we need to figure out how
to write a Java Script so and just
rephrase this if Emily if if I'm a
little fragment and I'm going to the if
I go into the web page what what is what
doesn't my environment look like what
can I assume being there in terms of
capabilities and in order to scale over
time for us we think that just having a
CSS reset a basic set of polyfills that
we agree upon and then having very
basic typography like the font and maybe
some header sizes allows us to have this
architecture so shared fragments have no
dependencies and we have these five
different services which are written in
a bit different ways so our editorial
content and the product pages are just
being static files on the CDN so we we
have uploaded over two million files to
the CDN today and it that's also a bit
of part of the great performance at m2
has on the product page we are using a
tiny amount of prayer code for some
interactive use cases and the first
version of search was also written in
pre-act now we have expanded on the
under search search service and a
dedicated team for that and it's being
helps has been were written in vue.js
and was actually released in austria
yesterday and so we allow ourselves to
have these different different
technologies depending on what the team
feels is the right right client-side
library for them or maybe not to use the
client library at all the check out is
more server-side technology I believe
it's using Java but I don't I'm not
really sure and we have a wish list
where you can add products to maybe the
by later maybe in the in a store in a
physical stores or to convert them into
shopping cart items later and that's
being written in react so just and this
I think this is a very nice place to be
because you're able to evolve piece by
piece to different different
technologies and to kind of find al like
a local Maxima for the service which in
turns helps us to have like a global
Maxima of in terms both of the
element like the teams can actually
choose themselves what they want to
build with depending on their their
scenarios and also to learn and adapt
what worked and what didn't and of all
the situation and a solution from there
so also in terms of performance like I
said in the beginning of this talk to
the favor a simple web pages as possible
but as you see here the shakeout and
wish list are very different from the
rhetoric content and the product so to
find a common way to have great
performance for for this range of
scenarios is it's very hard and I don't
think there is a solution for it but if
instead separate between services and
allow each service to have their own
their own style we can have a great
performance as possible for each service
so let's just checking time here yeah so
I'll say that compared to the other like
Micra front and styles of integrating
things on the client side I'll say that
technology diversity is it's not a it's
not a bug it's a feature that you can
have if you go towards this style of web
development in Manatee for many teams
and this is also as I believe to be the
core of a general market or architecture
that you allow yourself to have
diversity of different technologies and
that was that the promise of so a
service-oriented architecture do not
depend on a typical on a particular
runtime like Java or.net to be able to
mix and
yeah so just to sum up these design
constraints we are having these design
constraints in our project you might not
have them but if you have more than one
team and one time long live the valuable
solution with performance you'll have
them oh yes one more thing diversity
it's it's of course not great to have
hundred hundred different libraries or
frameworks so you have to find like a
couple of them just to be just to be
clear there's a diminishing return here
as well that where if you have two three
four that's okay but ten or twenty maybe
that's over over the top because it's
it's hard to share competence them
between the different teams all right so
these design constraints a quick recap
having simple and diverse services grace
gives us great per service performance
which gives us a good performance as you
can get with this set of services we're
using transclusion to get scalable
development with edge site includes as a
base technology and using some Ajax for
for your script components and pages and
for personalized content and these style
and script resources to be able to
deploy CSS and JavaScript files in a
good way and then to have no
dependencies between the shared
fragments in order to evolve the
solution over the years and and that's
it
that's the that's my talk there are some
resources here I made a kind of
manifesto style web page awhile ago
called Mike service websites with kind
of yeah very small number of rules or
constraints like as another spec but
more to towards that last summer one
half years ago I wrote an article over
30 pages so quite a lot of material
there's a thought works tech writer blip
for micro front ends
it was there two times I think and
there's a Twitter hashtag Micra front
dance and if you want to see how I key
mt Norway works there's the first URL if
you just want to check out with a
desktop or mobile and if you have a
mobile self smartphone just go to Ikea
DUP enno and you see how it works and
I'm happy to answer any questions or
discussions you have on Twitter after we
talk so I have three minutes I think so
any questions yes
okay so the question was can fragment
include other fragments and yes they can
for for airside includes we have a
naming convention so that we don't parse
fragments unnecessarily so we basically
have a - recursive suffix and then
you're doing si resolves and inside
parsing on the fragments that those kind
of fragments as well and we're using
that in in production as well
and for for Ajax if you use if you're
not using a include you have to find a
way to parse the document that you're
that you're having requesting but if you
use H include it's just that's just a
web component custom element so when the
when the Dom sees another eish included
in the fragment it will make another HS
call for that component which is not
great for performance since you have a
serialized number of requests but at
least it's possible and maybe you have
some use cases where you have to do that
the cost of your organization or other
constraints but good question another
question okay
okay so the question was how do you go
about scoping the CSS and that's also a
very good question and something that
I've left outside the talk so just to be
clear I'm not a c6 CSS expert but I also
believe that you'll having you'll have
this problem of scoping CSS regardless
of what way you have what Microsoft's
architecture have on the front end and
there exists of course many different
modules ways just to make some basic
thing in less or or what's order says
maybe CSS magis is a good thing I'm not
really a lever in the CSS in JavaScript
style but maybe I'm just old-fashioned
but you need to find a solution to
scoping CSS so you don't pollute the
global space but I won't go into details
on exactly how we're doing it we're
using BAM but that's not a guarantee and
of course the problem is the problem
with CSS it's not only of the namespaces
because even the whole screen can be
seen as a as a like global global
resource so we live really to think
about this from the ground up how you
actually design for the solution to be
kind of flexible enough to not have this
has subtle graphical bugs as well but
I'll happy to discuss after the talk and
I'm afraid that the time is up so thank
you so much for for listening and I will
be here afterwards if you want to
discuss Thanks
[Applause]